[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys we got
walter hong in the house
[Applause]
i was i was in memory land
all right you know how like we usually
we usually talk about funny funny fun
times right funny [ __ ] time like right
now it's pretty wild dude like war with
ukraine might be coming very soon you
know have you heard all the [ __ ]
interesting stuff that's happening in
the news have you heard the perspective
of um
like russian people that think that it's
fake really i think that there's not
really going to be a war and that it's
all just like this
propaganda thing whose perspective
americans perspective
russians perspectives russian people
russia like russian citizens like like
if the average russian person on ig or
whatever like well
yeah we'll come in and be like don't
believe that guys it's nothing yeah
that's funny because in korea or south
korea i have to specify south korea if
you when they interview people like oh
yeah north korea is not going to attack
they're not going to attack but you know
we think north korea is going to attack
yeah in our perspective right and then i
started thinking about this and i was
like
how do y'all know
you're not in the room where they decide
these things
like it's just oh this is the way i feel
no one cares how you feel watch it they
read the newsletter oh that's what it is
yeah
but then doesn't it make sense though
for york people like in your country to
not get scared because it all will break
loose
right if all south koreans were like oh
[ __ ] north korea's gonna invade again
[ __ ] god damn they're not gonna be
producing their hyundai's and [ __ ] like
everything would tank
can you [ __ ] make k-pop if you were
that scared i don't think so every k-pop
song would be like they're coming for us
they're coming for us you know but it'll
be catchy as [ __ ] they're coming for us
they're coming for us they're coming for
us by the way south korean music videos
are crazy they're so good they're the
best music videos you know what kpop
capitalize on are two things that
america left behind that we left behind
one was the music video new outfits
every outfit
i don't watch the office cause i'm a
dude but um unless they're sexy uh yeah
me neither you know cds
the capital of the cities korea leads
the
world in cd sales they still
you see these exactly because what they
do is they made it into a gift
remember back then when they had cds and
then they had the gift cd with photos
and stuff that's the regular cd for
k-pop do they still burn cds
they do photos they do they have photo
books so it's collectible
total collectible thing
i'm not saying i have like one or every
single ten of them yeah i'm not saying
that which ones do you have girl i'm not
saying i have black pink hot or you know
twice or whatever i'm not saying i was
at the twice concert last night i'm not
saying that good thing you're not saying
that walter if you're the wrong root
brother
we're gonna kick your ass
kid's collecting records today you know
it's like ooh this old relic vinyl i
don't know
kids is a strong word because i may or
may not have them still wrapped in the
plastic on display i may or may not have
that i don't want to you know go one way
or the other okay so i have a question
for you hypothetically said a really
good job on idolization yeah yeah very
hypothetically speaking how much could
you sell you know a black pink
album for right now not much okay but
but i've been scouring the chart all day
after world war three though this is
gonna be popping after world war three
and then it may or may not have my dna
on it yeah of course it may or may not
um would that be would that make it more
valuable today i would assume i would
say i think he was fan yeah
sounds like you hate this stuff
world-class walter hong that was on jk
news yeah
with
and their media has a different
perspective i remember when uh we first
went into iraq right and it was us
liberating them
and then i was at my korean homies house
and then we're watching korean news and
it says u.s invades iraq
you know it's just it's just so
different you're like wait yeah it's
just like it's just the
perspective cool to get to read
headlines just even just headlines
yeah like al jazeera readers do i trust
all of them no but at least you can see
what their perspectives are the
consensus yeah you know what blows my
mind though is like when we were growing
up right
conservatives the gop they were the
warmongering war loving [ __ ] bush
senior bush junior everybody was like we
need to [ __ ] go and like preserve
democracy they always say that [ __ ] we
need to save democracy right
and then you know the democrats were the
anti-war they were like no we can't
[ __ ] be doing this stuff whatever
whatever
and then i was like you know what i
think i think when biden gets elected
like i think we're gonna be either in a
war or like it's going to be a it's
going to be this like scary we might get
into a war right and then everyone's
like no no no because he's campaigning
on like he actually campaigned on like
more of a passive progressive approach
and i was like i don't think so dude
he's establishment man i don't think he
he believes what he says he's [ __ ]
bullshitting and then
here we are yeah for real ukraine
invasion to preserve democracy are we
invading for sure no uh so isn't it all
just supposed to be like a bluff like a
[ __ ] that's what i heard too chelsea
gabbard say that like the the way that
it could all just be diffused is if
america guarantees that ukraine won't
join nato but they're not doing that no
they're not going to do that and then
and the weird thing is the media is
already priming the american public to
believe that war is inevitable
so the ukrainian president himself came
out and said like no there's no like we
don't even have any intentions of doing
that whatever whatever and then russia
was like hey um you guys are violating
our
agreement that you're not gonna encroach
on our
uh border because after the cold war so
you know the cold war was
you know the europe was kind of divided
where you had the eastern bloc which is
like latvia romania all those eastern
european countries like uh they were a
part of the ussr and then germany was
divided into two right and then when the
ussr fell
all those countries became u.n nato
countries like romania and whatever
ukraine
it's not a nato country
it's kind of right in the middle and
there was a war a couple years ago i
think it was 2011 or something like that
a civil war but that's because there was
a lot of russian ethnic russians on the
east side and also russian sympathizers
that wanted ukraine to be
a part of russia
yeah and then if you saw like there was
a lot of [ __ ] like you know videos
that vice did of on location people
[ __ ] blasting each other up it was
nuts
so that kind of chilled out and then so
uh
i think the western part of ukraine
wants to be a part of u.n nato and all
that but they can't
actually ever be it because that would
cause crazy tensions between the west
western countries yeah and then um
russia so from russia's perspective it's
like this hey we had an agreement
and now the u.s is
you know during i think it was uh
obama's administration but he added
missiles in some eastern european
countries he added missiles there and he
goes that's an act of kind of war guys
like you're you're bringing [ __ ] to us
and then um while they were doing some
military exercises or whatever we
started supplying ukraine with u.s
military equipment that's how we do and
and whatever right and then so and from
russia's perspective
that's an act of war because it's like
you guys are arming
you know so so which is it is it are you
coming here to uh you know preserve
democracy which by the way ukraine is
not very
democratic for real dude like
they're completely corrupt
they're not a democratic country like in
the way that we feel like democracy
should be upheld they're [ __ ] which
are democracies perfect
well what they'll do is we love talent
the same thing we uh we we talk [ __ ]
about putin for which like is uh they
had some media agencies like let's say
if cbs was talking [ __ ] about trump
right and then trump decides to destroy
cbs via twitter yeah but basically
ukraine took down three uh news stations
because of criticism so they'll do crazy
[ __ ] like that and then so the west is
backing up a country that we criticize
russia for so for me
this is my own theory is that hunter
biden has uh business relations in
ukraine and so i think you know big
daddy biden is all he's doing is
protecting his son's companies so he's
using the u.s troops but that's just
that's just my little conspiracy kind of
business do you think 3 000
yeah oh the u.s troops allegedly there's
like 60 to 70 000 russian troops there i
heard they're starting to pull some
russian troops they they that's what
that's what the statement was yeah
they're not that's what it is it's like
which one is it like so russia said
we're going to we're going to move them
but then they're not
i think i think what they're doing is
honestly when they say move i think what
they mean is that we're moving the left
side the guys on the left to the right
and the guys on the right to the left oh
my god that's my switch
[Laughter]
if they have 60 000 troops there and we
just said three thousand
like it's nothing yeah like i know they
said they're paratroopers but i don't
care sixty thousand sixty thousand we're
like three hundred dude i think
ultimately it's also just like um catch
him in the bottleneck a little bit of um
everybody doesn't want to go to war
and the best way to deflect the war is
to show how like it's gonna like i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up yeah i'm so down i'll
go to war bro like no i don't want to
fight you but you know if i do this like
honestly you're all gonna die so i'm
going to do it just to show you you're
going to die but i don't want to fight
you all right then pull up that's that's
what we're going to cover then you're
like dude i'm not scared so i'll respond
like this but i want to fight you yeah
but like this is what we're going to do
if you do that yeah it's just a constant
game of chicken um with probably a bunch
of underlying conspiracy [ __ ] it would
be nice if politicians just apologized
yeah what happened like yo
why did i put these guys over here let's
let's take them out and the other guy's
like politicians yeah dude we'll take
our guys back you guys take your guys
back but it's always like advancing on
each other until [ __ ] some conflict
explodes
i i kind of like looked into that right
because i was like all right
it doesn't make sense for us to get into
world war iii it's bad business for
everyone because russia and china is
like kind of a trade handshake right and
then the other thread is taiwan right
where nihao wants to grab
taiwan oh yeah
nina wants to grab taiwan that's what we
call them now yeah that's what we call
them but just just how do you say hi in
russian
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
hello hello
oh wow today's video is brought to you
by curology
you might be wondering is it the asian
skin that keeps us young well partly
maybe it's genetic and i'm not even sure
if we look that young but i'm very proud
of my skin when i see myself in the
mirror because i've been working with
curology for the last two years and
they've been helping me get this
unlocked i've seen asians that look like
[ __ ] yeah me too yeah i think you did a
really good job and looks really good
thank you i'm a big fan of their
chapstick it comes out in a little stick
and it goes around my lips it's like a
lightsaber
very awesome yeah but they're really
easy to use you go online there's a quiz
you fill out what your skin goals are it
could be acne fine lines clogged pores
whatever you fill it out and then a
licensed dermatology provider will
create a custom formula just for you so
that it's made for you you're not buying
anything generic at the store and you
can have beautiful skin like joe and me
and it comes straight to your door when
you order this subscription and what's
awesome is it also has a moisturizer and
some face wash and it's a super easy
three-step process i do it in the shower
i just wash i wash the wash when i get
out i put my formula on and then i put
the moisturizer on to block it all up
and then i'm ready to go to start the
day
so if you want to start a free 30-day
trial just go to curology.com
off the record all you have to do is pay
five bucks for the shipping and that's a
free 30-day trial you could try for a
whole month to see if it makes a big
difference for you go to
curology.com off the record just pay
five bucks for the shipping
but if you think about it
nuclear war all-out war with two big
countries like let's say u.s and china
or whatever
it's actually not very profitable
because the production stops where like
you know china sells to our people we
need a manufacturer in china every the
whole world's connected so they do these
things called proxy wars where it's like
we'll fight in little countries we'll
make a little
we'll we'll do it that way right i'll
meet you behind the classroom like
[ __ ]
the basketball courts [ __ ]
like [ __ ] syria like [ __ ] yeah
we'll [ __ ] up these other countries
that's what they call the classroom [ __ ]
because it it doesn't make money for us
to [ __ ] each other up like each other
but i also think they have a poster and
everything yeah so so but i also think
there's a relationship with keeping so
for example north korea the enemy and
for them
to also stay there and and so what i
looked into was how uh these companies
like raytheon and and um
uh like all the uh boeing northrup
yeah so like the the military industrial
complex they get money
from the us taxpayers whenever [ __ ] hits
the fan
so uh this is [ __ ] crazy but russell
brand broke out this news out of all
people russell [ __ ] brand right if
you go on his channel he'll basically
have quotes from different contract
companies that they were already like
the salesmen were [ __ ]
they were there they were they were
celebrating because they're like we're
going to make a [ __ ] ton of money from
ukraine they're they're caught quoting
all this stuff so
damn if i was on industry i would say
you're going to make money off of
ukraine okay so we don't make money but
boeing does raytheon does because what
ends up happening is all right we need
orders of missiles we need orders of
this and whatever whatever right so then
they put in those orders because we have
a war coming and then they send all the
equipment there or we sell it to ukraine
and that's how a lot of this [ __ ] goes
down because it's it's really
robbing the taxpayer
from fake threats so i was like that's
[ __ ] crazy
what evil genius for sure yeah what do
you think about like going back to what
you were saying about how
it's not profitable for our countries to
be fighting with each other russia china
u.s
what do you think about there's a
narrative going around that instead of
doing it through proxy wars they also do
it through like
misinformation through oh yeah oh
espionage
that's that's been happening like russia
troll farms all that stuff so what are
rush russian troll farms so russian
troll farms and china does this too and
like also north korea they have some of
the uh biggest hacker teams government
funded hacker teams and we have them too
but they we've been doing this so
basically so it's okay because we
started it we're pretty good we're
pretty good but but they say that the
world war three is is not going to be a
physical war but an online war ooh
metaphor
oh
dude you're giving me ptsd remembering
this [ __ ] bro
so we're gonna trust future wars the
nerds is what you're saying basically
dude but so so this is scariest [ __ ]
there's an interview in the in the 80s
of this uh kgb defector he was a part of
the soviet union he came to the us and
and they did a whole [ __ ] interview
and he says that um
basically their strategy was like yeah
the ussr is gonna fall but not russia
we're just gonna change the face of what
russia is
the way we're gonna attack america is
not physically anymore we're just gonna
destroy it from the inside we're gonna
fund
you know like maybe people who feel like
yeah second-class citizens in america
maybe people who's been like the
minorities and who's the american itself
right yeah and then so socialist it's
working programs [ __ ] yeah honestly
it is working russians are good they'll
find all the people who who america has
been abandoning the most patriotic era
like exactly for real huh when has it
ever been this yeah
you have a flag up of the u.s flag
people kind of look at it as like oh
you're coming people are scared to
[ __ ] wait they're like i'm gonna
[ __ ] take my dog at least in
california at least in california
invaders look at the american flag as oh
the house has guns yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's leave no actually they'll rob it
first because to get the guns oh and
then they have weapons oh [ __ ] that's
actually that's not nice so if you have
a sign that says owner will shoot they
go maybe i can steal that from him yeah
because they they want guns that's crazy
so my dear friend told me like if you
have an american flag yeah obviously
patriarch it's cool but that's a signal
for home invaders that oh they have guns
so what looks like oh oh for real
i'm gonna put a flag on your house so
they break it down and they're gonna be
like where's the gun
there's nothing here
and you're just like they're naked like
haha jokes on you right here right here
he has an adt sign there's something to
protect in there
i need to get one of those signs to put
it outside of my house i have one yeah i
haven't put it out do you have adt no
you could buy two big ones on amazon one
of my houses had had 82 the tenant had
adt and they left and they left them so
i took them and he took the sign
and so i'm going to put him in my place
yeah he has brink's adt i also ordered
the the fake ones to my house before too
when i was living in alhambra
just in case just get a bunch of cameras
and then never get the service because
you don't want to pay the monthly fee
big sign this is smile you're on camera
yeah oh yeah those are good or be aware
of dog even though there's no dog that's
that's what i have i have a bunch of
beware of dog ones and then uh one time
the postmate was like standing on the
other side of the gate i was like dude
you just come in he's like
don't you have a dog
[Laughter]
you have all those signs b where a dog
owner will shoot an american flag and
then just barbed wire and then big
cameras smile you're on camera i think
it would be scary as if like just owner
is naked
oh dude
like at all times yeah all the time or
just like smile you're on camera
dude if you could suck your own penis
i'm going to go through that door i'm
going to break it yeah that's going to
be a peeping tom running through the
window you should get a naked graphic of
you just laying like that and it says
enter at your own risk
if you want to be seduced come on in
come on and then single and ready to
mingle
talking about making america implode
from the inside out i was watching one
of the episodes of uh on andrew
schultz's podcast and he was talking
about uh that's our competitor bro
you know he's talking about on tick-tock
how the algorithm here favors stupid
stupidity yeah yeah right so the more
you dance the more views you get but
then the one in china it's
um it's more intelligent stuff it's like
engineering engineering
so it's like the smarter they'll make
the culture yeah they'll make the youth
smarter and more productive
and so it reinforces that versus on ours
it's the more dumb and more clown you
are it's working god damn it implosion
that's why we need to make educational
content yeah that's that's not
misinformation because the thing with
that with that when i heard that thing
too is that and then crazy russia's
imploding america from the inside is
that when you say those theories the
average american be like
who can think that far ahead who's that
smart because they don't under because
they're not understanding that the
difference between professional athletes
and us people is vast yeah the
difference between professional schemers
and like those guys that crazy topple
governments is so vastly different than
us like we think like our politicians
are so stupid they can't do anything no
they know exactly what they're doing
they want us to think that they're
stupid yeah so they can go blindly and
hidden in plain sight and make all this
money
i would say i would i would even say 10
million views right there that was
that's the clipboard the schemers the
difference between the schemers and us
is even greater than athletes in us oh
yeah yeah the guys that have started
like the cia and like special operations
crazy it's been like that since world
war ii and they keep reinventing and
modernizing and developing it versus the
top athlete it's like there's the growth
is still like this right it's like the
michael jordan of yesterday might be
only a little bit not as good as maybe
like lebron if they played modern
basketball right but the
the technology and the tactics it's like
[ __ ] like exponential yeah look at
look at the old days when you know they
talk about like in japan and i think
created this as well probably china as
well as when they would do use um body
doubles
oh yeah when they went out because back
then there's no obviously there's no
there's no photos there's no internet so
if they're like oh and back then you
never saw the emperor in japan you never
saw the leaders in china or you never
saw the kings unless photos came out but
yeah so before was you never saw them
because they stayed in their palaces
yeah so if they said oh like you know
joe's the emperor but then they
presented me they'll believe i'm the
emperor they'll try to kill me yeah and
so that that logic and that scheme right
there to know yeah to know that the
people would would buy this is amazing
and then those same people they trained
their their mentees under them and they
train their men and now they're better
than they are then now you with today's
technology in today's time they're so
much better at they can walk into a room
and they'll just know like oh you're
like this you're like that you're like
this i know i can get away from all
these people whereas we walk into a room
and we're just like oh like you know
filipino japanese chinese you know like
that's all we see
yeah we see and then we think we're
smart we think we're smart you know
those guys though they know they walk
into a room they know for the win dude
have you seen facebook dilemma it's
crazy right so in there
um they showed how a russian troll farm
created two facebook groups right one
was uh uh like
more like radical muslim and one was
like a right-wing nationalist more like
alt-right right and then
they decided to protest on the same day
in like houston or some texas city
and so
they wanted to organize some type of
fight to go down so they infiltrated so
many facebook groups
and they pretended to be americans
to cause [ __ ] and then they do this in
the comments they do this on instagram
comments everywhere so you don't know if
it's a china bot a russian bot you don't
know if it's like a troll that's just
paid salary to come in and to create
hate and violence
what a great job i know crazy does
and then you know like i don't know if
you guys saw this i think it was like
last year or the year before google can
um do an automated voice that sounds
just like a human yeah and so they to
test it they call it they ordered a
pizza
and um no one knew that it was a fake
voice so the people
allegedly people within google and like
when they got let out people were
complaining like hey you can't do that
yeah so it needs to be identifiably yeah
oh my god this technology is amazing
that's a real guy
so you know other countries already have
this technology yeah they've already got
it they probably stole it or they made
it themselves so now if they're like oh
these are just bots typing but if it's
if you put a voice to it then it's like
oh this is a real person now yeah so
imagine like in the metaverse if
someone's just like organizing away this
is a real person because listen to them
talk this is the actual person now it's
now we're now putting a voice to these
to these people and they're high yeah
and and they have pixel boobs damn
picking the right places pixel boobs get
your boy going
huh and extra cheese please
[Music]
[Music]
you